regardez bien ceci est pourtant une
plage celle de sainte anne la palud dans
le finistère une plage transformé par
les vacanciers en un vaste parking
nous avons vu trois mille véhicules
venir ainsi s'approprier l'espace
généralement réservé ailleurs aux jeux
de plage ou aux baigneurs
le moment on n'a aucune solution étant
donné qu'on n'a pas de nos moyens sont
pas suffisantes pour les voitures ya
déjà les routes réservées limité à la
vitesse et tous ils envahissent les
plages on n'a qu'à leur donner les
plages et puis garder les routes pour
nous soumettre à bronzer
certains trouvent une facilité et
justement se déplacer la voiture sur la
plage de la possibilité pour déshabiller
pour des quais de tout pas ces pratiques
avec les enfants ça point de repère à
les voitures ça point de repère les gens
édition la garenne est offert leur aide
servier clair cette journée de base
excluant les accidents graves
y'en a pas eu heureusement
mettons les craintes je rentre des états
bon ça mène ici moi c'est ce que je fais
on vient ici bonbons s'arrête ça va ce
qu'ils font du rodéo ça devient japy
critique